c'est à Patrick 37 ans qui est
conducteur de bus à la RATP qui dort
dans sa voiture depuis plus d'un an
faute d'argent et témoignant TPMP vous
allez voir ce témoignage est
complètement fou Patrick va nous
raconter son histoire depuis le début de
l'hiver déjà trois sans abri sont morts
dans la rue alors qu'Emmanuel Macron
avait dit de ne plus en vouloir dans la
rue avant fin 2017 mais Patrick lui il
est conducteur de bus il travaille et il
dort dans sa voiture après avoir été
expulsé de son logement je vous dis
c'est ce qui arrive de plus en plus
fréquemment maintenant d'en parler vous
allez voir le témoignage de Patrick SDF
échauff de bus c'est un truc de fou
regardez Réap il est avec
nous tandis que le froid s'est durement
installé ces derniers jours dans
l'Hexagone 330000 personnes seraient
sans domicile fixe sur notre territoire
une situation alarmante alors que les
Français sont touchés de plein fouet par
l'inflation et par une intense crise du
logement que vous voulez acheter ou
louer un logement relève souvent du
parcours du combattant et cette crise du
logement touche même des personnes
salariées selon la Fondation abépierre
un/art des sans abris auraiit un emploi
aujourd'hui
l'emploi ne protège pas forcément la
pauvreté on le sait malgré son CDI et de
multiples démarches Patrick conducteur
de bus âgé de 57 ans ne parvient pas non
plus à se loger faute d'argent
conséquence le quinagner à bouonner est
obligé de dormir dans sa voiture depuis
plus d'un an je ne sais pas où aller je
suis perdu il témoigne ce soir dans
TPMP merci Patrick d'être avec nous SDF
et chauffeur de bus merci d'être là dans
quelle circonstance vous avez perdu
votre logement que vous écouttiez
vraiment ce témoignage vous allez voir
qui est complètement fou et qui est pas
juste un témoignage comme ça d'une
personne voilà qui qui qui qui estolé
voilà il y en a plein des témoignages
comme ça vous avez perdu votre logement
pourquoi suite à un amour d'avoir aimé
une personne d'avoiré une femme qui
était pas de nationalité française
africaine j'en étais tellement amoureux
que je lui ai donné tout pouvoir ah oui
donc c'est quoi l'histoire parce que
racontez-nous c'est même ça c'est fou
don en tout pouvoir vous l'avez
rencontré comment par le Billis d'
l'Internet d'accord et elle vivait sur
la France d'accord et donc vous l'avez
rencontré par internet et donc là vous
tombez F amourux F en aiguille les
choses sont venues qu'on est ben l'amour
s'est fait quoi l'amour s fait donc là
vous habitez avec elle non non
actuellement je suis dans ma voiture non
mais et là là après après oui après on
elle est venue s'installer chez moi elle
a pu connaître maman qui est décédé peu
de temps après d'accord et qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé en fait vous avez mis tout à
son nom non je j'avais tout mon nom mais
je lui donnais parce que les TR F enfin
bon les organismes prenaient toujours
l'argent n'importe quand et n'importe
est bien fort Patrick vous entend pas
bien je vous disais donc les organismes
comme les trois F de logement me faisait
jusqu'à trois prélèvements par mois
d'accord alors que c'est un prélèvement
de loyer quand même donc il a fallu que
je règle les choses donc je payais par M
cache vous êtes encore avec cette cette
jeune femme ou pas du tout
terminé vous savez ENF je mon histoire
est un peu compliquée parce que j'en
étais tellement amoureux bon elle est
partie elle était pas c'était pas
quelqu'un de fidèle mais je pensais
qu'elle aurait changé on pense des fois
que les chens peuvent changer par
l'amour mais l'amour pour elle c'est le
portefeuille c'est pas autre chose je
peut-être cru dans ce que je vais dire
mais bon il y a des femmes de bien il y
en a des pas bien malheureusement je
suis pas tombé sur la bonne personne
c'est vrai que certains soirs j'aimerais
bien avoir une épaule elle vous a
arnaqué c'est ça
plus qu'arnaquer abusé de ma confiance
ce qu'elle a fait beaucoup de choses
vous nous dire ou pas du tout
c'est un peu privé quand même vous savez
nous les hommes je veux pas nous
rabattre nous les hommes mais nous avons
deux cerveaux la studio auss du bas elle
a fait dij studio pour faire Mach du bas
c'est ça et donc vous avez fait
n'importe quoi pas n'importe quoi c'est
que je lui ai laissé pouvoir et puis en
fin de compte voilà c'est ça qui a fait
que vous êtes retrouvé à la rue donc
voilà donc elle a s'est arrangé pour
détruire tout tout ce qui tout ce que
j'aurais pu avoir comme résolution pour
pouvoir essayer de de défendre pas
perdre mon appartement que j'ai
j'habitais déjà avantant avant de la
connaître dedans mais pourquoi en fait
vous avez perdu votre appartement par
qu' on comprend pas le les les impayés
du loyer parce que je lui donnais
l'argent pour payer le gaz électricité
loyer elle payait gaz électricité loyer
donc au début c'était bien je faisais
j'ai fait confiance parce que au bout de
3 ans on peut faire comm confiance à une
personne 3 ans avec elle oh 7 ans
presque non ah ouais et vous êtes pas
rendu compte de la non la super ch non
parce que la super cherie non vous savez
après quand on est amoureux on dit
toujours ça rend aveugle moi je dis
rajouterai des mot derrière ça rend
idiot et très sourd ah ouais et donc et
donc là elle payait pas le loyer c'est
ça voilà donc elle payait pas le loyer
puis Gard pour elle voilà c'est et elle
a disparu donc vous lui donnez l'AR
matin les iciers la police les
serruriers qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
quoi ce délire et puis bon voilà quoi
comment comment elle a disparu du jour
au lendemain prtendant qu'elle devait
partir voir quelqu'un de la famille vous
l'avez plus jamais revu non elle m'a
juste téléphoné le 24 décembre 2022 on
m' P sent que je sais ce qui t'arrive
c'est ton problème moi je suis ailleurs
24 décembre donc cadeau de Noël quoi
ouais c'est par cadeau de Noël ou vous
assurer que le 2 décembre dernier ça m'a
marqué et donc là elle vous annonce quoi
elle vous annonce queelle a elle un payé
qu'elle a pris tout l'argent non non
elle m'a rien dit elle m'a dit tu de
merère c'est ton problème c'est
incroyable et donc et donc là vous vous
on tape à votre porte vous vous le
saviez vous étiez au courant pas du tout
donc là quand on tape à votre porte vous
ben vous savez quand on vous anon c'est
la police bon qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce que fait j'ai pas tué personne
pour l'instant sû donc là vous vous
doutez pas du tout de pourquoi il
vienent non c'est quand la luissière m'a
expliqué le
problème d'accord mais il m'a dit
monsieur vous êtes expulsé mais je dis
mais comment ça expulsé vous m'avez pas
envoyé de recommander enfit il y a des
choses il y a une procédure quand même
avant d'expulser une personne de mettre
dehors unici mais vous avveit jamais
répondu bah j'ai dit ah bon bah j'ai
jamais reçu de lettre elle était partie
depuis combien de temps presque de mois
donc ouais donc d'accord donc là qu'elle
a détérioré beaucoup de choses d'accord
et moi j'ai pas vous savez quand on a un
moment on voit pas toujours tout mais
vous aviez pas payé le le dernier moi je
lui donn moi je lui donné les sous lui
faisant
confiance quand on fait confiance au
bout de 3 ans de surveiller la personne
on on on peut faire continuer à faire
confiance à cette personneel quand même
mais il y avait combien donc j'ai voulu
avancer pay il y avait combien on a payé
voilà on est à plus de 20000 € ah 20000
€ elle a pas payé le loyer pendant
combien de temps pendant euh 3 ans ah
ouais oui plus de 3 ans elle gardait et
elle gardait tout l'argent pour elle les
lettres elle les garda pour elle donc
vous voyez pas qu'il y avait des
problèmes intercep et et donc et quand
elle vous a dit le 24 décembre tu te
démerdes vous avz dit quoi je dit mais
je savais que tu étais une
garce maintenant je diraiis rien de plus
vous savez chacun on a le droit de se
tromper l'être humain a toujours le
droit de faire des erreurs j'ai fait
l'erreur de connaître cette personn là
ça me coûte très cher parce que vivre
dans la rue ça coûte très cher justement
parce que votre histoire est pas fini he
21h5 vous êtes avec nous en direct euh
avec Patrick euh donc votre salaire nous
permet pas de payer un loyer maintenant
c'est ça pourquoi vous êtes dehors
maintenant parce que vous êtes chauffeur
de bus mais vous êtes dehors donc j'ai
travaillé pour
Transdev où j'ai demandé euh une aide
parce que j'ai vu que c'était un peu la
galère administrativement parce que dans
l'administration française on aime bien
faire traîner les choses et une tonne de
papier à chaque fois on veut faire des
économies mais enfin bon je parlerai pas
sur les économies du papier mais enfin
il en faut quand même un des papiers
donc j'ai demandé un petit coup de main
de lappment de mon responsable mon
responsable m'a dit euh euh que c'était
mon problème bah tout le monde vous dit
c'est votre problème c'est mon problème
et puis que la phrase qui m'a sorti
j'aurais pu lui casser tout ses dent si
je voulais mais je suis pas rentré dans
la violence c'est quoi il vous a dit
quoi il y aura rien et il y aura jamais
rien pour toi tu es SDF enfin sans dire
ce motl tu resteras ouais un responsable
de dépô qui vous sort ça mais la
direction de Transdev et en bouge qui
c'est fau alors donc on vous a dit tu es
c'est la merde en
fait vous avez porté plainte contre
votre ex compomagne ou c'est pas
possible il y a rien à faire il y a rien
à faire en fait vous savez une femme
sera toujours défendu sera mieux perçu
qu'un homme oui mais bon là là là là
quand même c'est de l'escroquerie on
peut considérer ça comme de
l'escroquerie but de confiance c'est se
ou mais B qu'est-ce que je veux fairei
quand je vois déjà quand je vois déjà
que je c à la porte pour essayer d'avoir
un logement qu'on me dit non vous aurez
pas de logement j'ai un petit chat on
m'a proposé un hébergement pour mon chat
mais à moi on m'a pas proposé quoi que
ce soit vous êtes dans la rue vous êtes
dans la rue depuis combien de temps
depuis le 20 le 20 octobre 2022
ouais ouais quand même ça date donc là
vous êtes vous êtes dans la rue vous
êtes vous dormez dans votre voiture h
comment ça se passe pour vous parce que
on se POS question j'ai trois journées
en une vous êtes donces chauffeur de
est-ce que pour nous raconter vos
journées parce que c'est fou les gens là
sont quand je dire j'ai commencé à
travailler cet après-midi donc ce matin
je me suis levé assez tôt donc vous êtes
dans votre voiture
dormez dans votre voiture d'accord là
j'ai dormi au dépôt parce queil y a de
quoi dormir au dépôt mais je veux pas
que les gens me voient je veux pas faire
paraître pource que je ne suis pas donc
là vous dormez dans la voiture parfois
enfin le plus souvent vous levez vous
levez à quelle heure je dors 3h par nuit
3 4h par nuit vous arrivez plus à dormir
de toute façon de toute façon il quand
vous êtes dans votre voiture il faut
faire attention à tout ce qui se passe
he ouais ça donc il faut aller se cacher
des fois très loin dans le 77 pour
pouvoir revenir sur le 93
quoi ben vous savez je j'ai une voiture
je l'avais avant j'ai une jolie voiture
c'est une Audi a 4 il y a rien de
spécial dans une a 4 c'est un vieux
modèle ouais mais bon comme je
l'entretiens vous savez les jeunes ils
sont toujours prêts à faire quoi que ce
soit je veux dire je vais pas
généraliser surtout les jeunes non plus
quoi et donc vous essayez de dormir le
plus lo possible vous avez peur la nuit
au début j'ai eu peur maintenant vous
êtes habitué donc vous dormez dans votre
voiture vous réveill à quelle heure ce
matin je me suis lu à 5h30 du matin pour
commencer à me faire la beauté vous vous
rasez où vous faites vous faites vous
lavez où avec des lingettes quand je
trouve quand je trouve pas de toilette
publique ou alors je vais dans une
piscine pour faire du sport en même
temps comme ça ça me peut faire un peu
de sport ça me décrasse aussi un petit
peu et puis il y a les touches publiques
aussi vous gagnez combien par par mois
1800 € 1800 € mais 1800 € c'est sont
dépensé dans la dans entre la nourriture
manger et essayer de survivre de pas
vivre de survivre je précise impossible
d'avoir un nouveau logement avec les
textes de loi qui ont été posé non donc
là vous êtes dans la rue vous vous dites
comment comment vous allez vous en
sortir parce que votre quotidien c'est
dormir dans la voiture vous comptez
dormir dans votre voiture
c'est pas j'ai jamais demandéêre SDF et
j'ai jamais demandé à vouloir dormir
dans une
voiture mais vous vous dites que ça va
durer indéfiniment ça c'est quoi votre
solution la solution je frappe à des
portes là j'ai changé de société parce
que là où j'étais avant c'était
inadmissible vous un esclave et
l'esclavagisme est interdit mais bon ça
existe encore ils n'ont pas de cœur ces
gensl de transd ce qui les intéresse
c'est remplir lez 57 ans vous avez des
enfants vous avez une il vous disent
quoi vos enfants vous avez honte de leur
demander de vous aider c'est ça vous
voulez pas vous dites moi je veux me
démerder tout
seul
c'est aujourd'hui c'est quoi 5 jour
c'est c'est une épreuve je suis en
épreuve tous les jours à chaque
instant votre vie c'est c'est j'ai trois
j'ai trois vies en une ce matin je me
suis lavé préparé pour être présentable
devant les clients parce que j'adore mon
métier de conduire les bus malgré que le
métier ils l'ont cassé complètement donc
je parlerai pas de qui est qui il y en a
C vous savez très bien que le le milieu
du transport on va bientôt faire
travailler des rouains si ça continue à
des prix disoire alors qu'il y a des
textes de loi nous sommes inclus s sous
des responsabilités monsieur connais
là-bas qui est en face de moi connaî le
milieu du transport il fait le milieu du
transport donc il sait très bien que la
fimon tout ça le milieu du le le permis
D est un des plus
compliqués aujourd'hui vous vous sentez
abandonné par par tout le monde un peu
oui là depuis peu depuis peu je vois
certaines lueurs mais vous savez ce sont
des lueurs c'est une lumière qui est au
fond d' c'est quoi les lueurs dites-mi
j'ai changé de société je suis parti à
RATP c'est déjà pour ne plus avoir
l'emprise de d'être d'être considéré
comme un esclave ouais et excusez-moi la
RH de la RATP ils vous ont fait un
entretien parce qu'il y a le 1% oui mais
je leur quand je suis rentré à RATP je
l'aurais pas dit que j'étais SDF ah
voilà par que j'ai caché j'ai caché
c'est vrai que c'est peut-être pas bien
d'avoir mais tuoyer tu parlais du du
boulot la passion de conduire mais c'est
aussi une grosse responsabilité c'est
pour ça que le pèmid est compliqué mais
tu peux pas dormir dans ta voiture et
après avoir la responsabilité de
transporter 80 personnes qui vont au
boulot et je pense que la RATP ils vont
peut-être faire un truc parce qu'ils
peuvent pas RP va sûement
bougerèémission te laisser prendre un
bus si tu as pas dormi de la nuit alors
justement Patrick c'est vrai que quand
vous me disiez et téléspectateurs sont
vraiment halluciné par votre témoignage
comme vous me disiez vous avez trois
vies racontez-moi vos trois vies en une
jour en une journée ben le matin c'est
se préparé comme ce matin ma vie de
travailler C à quelle heure Beni j'ai
commencé à MH mon service quand vous
terminez à quelle heure j'ai terminé il
était presque 20h votre vous êtes vous
vous avez envoyé quelqu'un qui venu qui
m'amené jusqu'à vos studio merci de me
recevoir non mais ça me fait ça me fait
très plaisir et Patrick aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous avez des amis qui vous
soutiennent est-ce que vous arrivez
encore à avoir une vie sociale ou pour
vous ça y est vous êtes complètement
brisé une vie sociale on peut pas en
avoir on est obligé de se je je veux pas
faire voir ce que je suis pas donc SDF
c'est pas mon trôle c'est pas mon rôle
et je des amis c'est
compliqué vous savez j'essaie de parler
avec des gens donc ça m'est arrivé de
rencontrer différents sexes hommes et
femmes bien sûr et euh là vous savez
quand vous leur dites je suis SDF j'ai
besoin de parler avec quelqu'un c'est
limite vous savez le SDF on le jette par
terre on va lui cracher dessus hein on
s'en fout de il peut crever dans la rue
Mo dans excusez-moi d'être vulgaire non
mais non vous êtes pas vulgaire du tout
on comprend tout à fait ce que vous
dites ce que vous je veux pas finir dans
un canivau ouais alors que je travaille
et que je paye des impôts parce que j'ai
des impôts qui sont pris mon salaire
mais quand je fais mes courses j'achète
une baguette je paye une TVA c'est des
imp direct ou j'achète une boîte de
consert pour manger essayer de faire
chauffer une boîte de conserve dans une
voiture c'est pas mal quand même comment
fa j'ai pas de F microondes he ah
non votre vie depuis octobre 2022 votre
vie c'est ça vous après quand j'ai fini
ma journée je je me
change après je réfléchis je pense là on
m'a on m'a pris en photo là c'était
place de la Nation je veux place de la
Nation je vais n'importe quel ban public
Ahou puis quand il fait pas mauvais
comme aujourd'hui maement il plus donc
c'est pas l'idéal mais je me pose sinon
j'essaie de manger un petit morceau et
puis d'essayer de penser à autre chose
de voir autre chose c'est incroyable
vous êtes au donc c'est vrai que j'ai
plusieurs passions je je joue à la
pétonque donc à 3h du matin les places
de la nation vous allez avir la couillon
qui vous jouer à la pétante ça va être
moi ah ouais appelez-moi la prochaine
fois ah ben si vous voulez venir jouer
avec il y a pas de problème en plus je
suis un ancien arbitre avec grand
plaisir puis non mais franchement et
après je fais du servolant aussi bon
c'est pas du servolant de compétition
mais ça me fait penser à autre chose ça
me vide l'esprit et le weekend vous
faites quoi les weekends pour moi c'est
une antise c'est ça le weekend c'est
c'est l'enfer dès que je suis de repos
je je sais pas ce que je sais pas o
faire quoi faire faites quoi le weekend
vous essayez de faire quoi dès qu'
arrive le vendredi le vendredi soir vous
êtes
anéanti pas anéanti parce que j'essaie
de surmonter toutes ces épreuves donc je
vis à la minute
ouais weekend dernier vous avez fait
quoi par exemple je me suis promené dans
les galeries donc c'est les promotions
donc je peux pas me permettre d'acheter
parce que mon coffre c'est c'est mon
armoire ouais c'est ma caisse à outil
aussi pourtir ma voiture donc ben je
regarde je de voir les gens bouger ça me
permet de pas penser à ce qui m'arrive
d'essayer de faire face à ce genre de
chose et c'est compliqué Patrick j'ai je
vous dis j'ait é extrêmement touché par
par votre votre affaire merci je sais
que je sais que vous n'aimez pas
demander je sais que je demande rien à
personne on m'a toujours appris de Me
débriller par soi-même je sais
maintenant moi ce soir j'aimerais vous
proposer une petite aide petit coup de
pouce si vous le voulez bien
je je me suis permis de réserver pour
vous un hôtel jusqu'au mois de
mai un hôtel juste à côté du studio qui
a un hôtel vous allez être très très
bien he jusqu'au mois de
mai avec le petit déjeuner tous les
matins avec les équipes en place pour
vous vous serez au parchand Mariotte
donc situé à Boulogne ils ont été très
touchés par votre histoire également il
ont tout de suite répondu présent pour
vous accueillir donc bravo à eux merci
et donc à partir de ce soir vous avez
votre chambre qui vous attend donc dans
cet hôtel 4re étoiles qui est magnifique
je vous dit c'est beaucoup trop pour moi
j'ai jamais demandé tout ça dès ce soir
dès ce soir donc là vous rentrez là-bas
et euh j'espère que ça va vous permettre
de vous donner un petit coup de pouce
vous allez pouvoir
repartirespère vraiment je vous souhaite
beaucoup de bonheur et euh voilà
j'espère que ça va vous mettre un petit
peu de Bom au cœur et que ça vous
permettre dear ça va déjà me remettre on
va pas dire sur les railes mais ça va
déjà me permettre de me ressourcer un
peu plus de retrouver la la sérénité
mais la sérénité ne sera pas toujours là
alors et deuxième chose c'est vous serez
à 100 m de du studio donc vous venez
nous voir comme vous voulez et oui je
vais pas venir vous embêter ah bah si si
vous m'embêtez jamais le seul qui embête
les gens c'est moi donc vous inquiétez
pas et vraiment on sera très content de
vous voir et pouvez venir voir com vous
voulez vous nous donnez des nouvelles he
parce que sinon je vais venir prendre le
petit déj avec vous mais il y a pas de
pas de problème je vous invite à ma
table avec plaisir donc à partir de ce
soir vous allez juste à côté et vous
allez au Mariotte vous êtes attendu et
Patrick on espère vraiment que vous
allez pouvoir reprendre une vie normale
en tout cas vous êtes à l'hôtel jusqu'en
mai donc voilà pour les février mars
avril maisi voilà les merci merci à vous
merci à la production merci merci à
l'hôtel aussi merci au merci Patrick
d'avoir été avec merci à T mon merci
merci merci